[Música]
economía en directo américa ya está
conmigo en el estudio daniela a blandón
dani bienvenida feliz mañana hablemos de
la economía de mi natal venezuela porque
parece estar retomando la senda del
crecimiento para raúl muy buenos días y
un feliz día al periodista para usted
felicidad periodista en esos días
gracias pues mire el observatorio
venezolano de finanzas debe saberlo
usted es una instancia independiente
integrada por expertos económicos y a
veces le creen más inclusive que a los
mismos datos gubernamentales pues este
organismo informó que la actividad
económica que no es lo mismo que el pib
toca aclarar lo subió 6,8 por ciento en
2021 gracias a un aumento de la
producción petrolera la cifra oficial ya
sabemos no se publica desde el 2019
aunque también es producto del efecto
rebote después de contracciones cercanas
al 26 por ciento en los dos años
anteriores como vemos en el gráfico
ahora ni que quiere decir que el país no
ha llegado a niveles pre pandemia porque
recordemos que igual antes de la
pandemia estaba muy mal claro raúl es
que estas cifras hay que mirarlas con
mucha cautela porque si por ejemplo se
compara la producción de bienes y
servicios de 2021 frente a 2012 se
refleja una caída del 75 por ciento en
este periodo las noticias sin embargo no
son del todo malas este mismo
observatorio cree que falta apenas un
mes de inflación anual por debajo del
50% para que oficialmente se pueda decir
que esta nación salió de la
hiperinflación un fenómeno que el banco
central de venezuela ya dio por
terminado desde diciembre pasado mira
que los amigos del genio danny están en
todo lado porque en eeuu se destapó un
multimillonario fraude con las cripto
mafias que no leen las que siempre hemos
advertido acá ojo porque no son páginas
y porque no son reguladas por ninguna
autoridad económica pues el departamento
de justicia dijo que había desentrañado
lo que llamó el robo de cripto monedas
más grande de la historia dos
incipientes influencers corporativos
neoyorquinos fueron capturados el martes
acusados de conspirar para lavar dinero
proveniente del robo de bitcoins
entonces 16
ellos habrían aprovechado la saqueo de
la empresa vita fimex que es una de las
principales plataformas de intercambio
de script o monedas para los que creen
que esto no se puede hackear y se
apropiaron de unos 120 mil bitcoins snes
entonces el botín costaba 71 millones de
dólares pero a precio de hoy estamos
hablando de unos 4500 millones de
dólares de los cuales el departamento de
justicia dijo que ya recuperó unos 3.600
millones escuchamos a
stewart esta es la mayor incautación de
cripto divisas jamás realizada por las
fuerzas de seguridad estadounidenses
también es la mayor incautación
financiera del departamento en su
historia el mensaje a los delincuentes
es claro la cripto moneda no es un
refugio seguro podemos y lo haremos
seguir el dinero sin importar la forma
que tome no matter what it takes
danny y entonces le pregunto cómo va
usted con las plataformas tecnológicas
de los bancos qué tal se hallaba con la
tecnología y la banca yo nunca volví a
utilizar nunca volví a hacer una fila en
un banco yo tampoco de verdad que es una
pérdida de tiempo y agradecemos esa
tecnología pero los adultos mayores en
españa no están muy contentos con toda
esta transformación digital que estamos
viviendo y sobre todo en la banca porque
y quiero que le ponga atención al nombre
de la campaña se llama soy mayor no
idiota esto es un señor un pensionado
español de 78 años que la lanzó se llama
carlos sanjuán y fue recibido en la
oficina del propio secretario general
del tesoro carlos cuerpo a donde llegó
con 600 mil firmas recolectadas a favor
de su iniciativa que busca que la banca
preste mayor atención a las personas
mayores concretamente la molestia tiene
que ver con que los cuatro principales
bancos del país que son santander bbva
caixabank y sabadell hayan cerrado el 27
por ciento de sus sucursales en 2021 al
tiempo que alcanzaba récord de ganancias
en perjuicio de aquellos como el que no
están acostumbrados a la banca
electrónica limpia vamos a ver quiero
voluntariamente que aprenda internet que
aprendan metaverso que aprenda chino si
es inclusive pero realmente hay
muchísima gente que lo que no va a
llegar a eso si aprende algo se le va a
olvidar entonces evidentemente la medida
que queremos urgente es la humanización
es la apertura en horas de oficina si
ellos han eliminado demasiados empleados
que rectifiquen se han precipitado le
han hecho visceralmente vamos a ver
entonces qué va a pasar con esta
exigencia daniela claro por supuesto
pero ahora le pregunto por los
indicadores de las acciones asiáticas
avanzaron después de una muy buena
sesión previa en wall street estamos
pendientes de conocer el dato de
inflación de enero en eeuu una fortaleza
que se trasladó también a las acciones
europeas que suben más del 1 por ciento
a media jornada y cifra el día 16 mil
millones de dólares esto es lo que pide
la organización mundial de la salud en
ayudas a los países ricos para acabar
con la pandemia en 2022 es a través de
la iniciativa llamada acelerador act que
fue creada específicamente para mejorar
el acceso de los más necesitados
los invito a que hagamos un ejercicio
rápido la fortuna calculada de los más
que el dueño de tesla es de 238 mil
millones adivinen cuántas veces alcanza
a pagar estos días dicen por supuesto y
en verdad para el digamos que no es
mucho daniela muchísimas gracias
entonces por toda la información
económica nos vemos más adelante
nosotros vamos a ver nuestro reportaje
del día